first off we'll have your birthday thank
you yeah we're gonna say the age can we
save the age no where I can finish how
old how old you are it's easily Google a
bull picture I know that sometimes
that's one of the things that I don't
like about the Internet is like people
can see how old I am for real you can't
I feel like it used to be you could lie
about your age right now you can't right
yeah I'm doing right now I'm sure some
[Music]
35:49 today yeah yeah how does that feel
feels pretty good yeah still under the
50 yeah
is that scary is that marks I mean it's
a big one for sure if one more year one
more year do and then what I'm 50 I'm
really gonna buckle down in terms of
what I'm gonna grow up let me feel okay
figure out what I want to do I've had a
really extended adolescence right a lot
of training a lot of training they've
just been kind of figuring it out and
now I'm gonna buckle down right yeah so
you're spending your birthday here or
laughter is the best medicine
not the first time you've been here it's
our fourth one yeah yeah so tell me a
little bit about this event
well this event it's it's a great event
you know we to to support the Michael
Guerin hospital formerly Toronto East
General and it's a great Community
Hospital and I got involved a number of
years ago because of my dad and a few
other things and it's just a really
great hospital that serves a community
that really needs it and so I just I
love an underdog yeah and it felt like
they were the underdog and at the time
when we started they really needed the
help and they still do and it you know
we we were able to the first one get
Jerry Seinfeld to come up and do it and
the second we had rock you know Chris
Rock came and did it
there were Jim Gaffigan this time we've
got Michelle wolf Jerry D opening four
and Jerry's awesome so it's just you
know we've managed to get really great
funny people to come and make this event
into something that's really fun for a
great cause right and so for me it's
it's pretty easy and you're the master
of Sam ways always love that title it's
very regal it's nice nice title yeah so
do you
to be the master of ceremonies for this
oh it's a lot of push-ups and a lot of
laps yeah and it's a last-minute things
do you do before you do a gig like this
or anything speaking thing not really I
mean you know I'm not a stand-up so I
try to like I try to just I'm there to
kind of set the tone welcome everybody
and I try to you know try to get this
the whole thing moving in a positive
direction if you will and and then once
we're rolling just kind of ride on the
coattails of you know Michelle and Jerry
you know what I mean and not mess it up
right you think laughter is the best
medicine
I think medicine is the best medicine
and I really I was like second I felt
pretty true to that I've always
maintained that if I walk into a
hospital and they're they're gonna try
to cure me with laughter right then I'm
going to another hospital
let's not be but I do think that
laughter is super therapeutic and it's
super you know it's important your
attitude is really important in life in
general and if you if you're laughing it
means that you're in a kind of a
positive place and and I think that
that's a really great thing and
obviously you're gonna tell some jokes
up on stage I hope so yes yeah but I
wonder do people always expect you to be
funny like when they run into you
somewhere or they always like want the
funny world fair or Will Ferrell Will
Arnett well they do want the world for
El Faro when they meet me they often do
well nobody you know it's funny that you
say Will Ferrell because you know when
you spend time with with will he
represents to a lot of people kind of
party funny crazy they love him you know
as Hank the tank or whatever so you'll
be walking with will people come like
what right they're like you're crazy
right
and he's like no it's Wednesday at 3:00
like I'm not crazy today and that's sort
of similar people do expect you to they
come up and they yell Arrested
Development quotes at you and they're
you know the chicken dance
not really I'm just coming back from the
grocery store dude like yeah what do you
want grocery store nearest but you don't
I mean theoretically right yeah where do
you get more do you get you have more
Arrested Development or more fat man
like with the Batman voice are here like
I've made a huge mistake yeah you still
get
you get I get I get both I got a huge
mistake or come on or I get Lego Batman
stuff especially with the with the
little kids which is great I get a lot
of aren't you that aren't you that horse
from horsing around which are Bojack
horseman reference so I feel like it
kind of runs the gamut right and I
always think it's funny when people
approach and like I know that they're
like waiting to say the thing and then
they say the thing because it takes a
lot I kind of weirdly it takes a lot of
guts through it can you always predict
what they're fans of like when someone's
approached to do like oh this is
Arrested Development fanboy that's a
good that'd be a good game yeah just do
that get like 10 people together who
would potentially maybe approach me and
then I have to guess what their fans up
right that's alright that's a good game
show although it's a little presumptuous
that there'd actually be 10 people it
would want to approach me or annoying
right now in terms of you're talking
about kids approaching you with with
Batman or your kids like are your own
kids like the ideal Lego Batman fans
like are they into it they're right in
the zone they are into it they love it
is it weird that their dad is the voice
of them they love it they do I love it
and they're also kind of over it right
we've done we've done you know between
the two Lego movies and the Lego Batman
movie is now three movies as Lego Batman
they're like we get it dude they think
you're funny yes okay they do I think so
but there are moments where they think
that I'm pretty much just you know dad
funny right but I also know what that is
and I try to embarrass them as much as
possible right okay so they're like ten
in ten yeah you can so do they realize
this would they totally get what dad
does oh um does so they get it now yeah
yeah yeah completely yeah they get it
and they're okay with it yeah well they
got no choice
which is that what I keep telling we're
in this for the long haul guys right
yeah I was singing terms of your
on-screen brother Jason Bateman yeah
he's all of a sudden getting all this
attention for being a dramatic actor I
know is that surprising to any field it
varies does he have a chip on his
shoulder not like he's winning awards he
barely has a shoulder so rounded in the
shoulder Department so if a chip could
stay there it would but yeah you know
he's so great in Ozark I'm such a I love
the guy to death and I'm just such a fam
always a to also
so it's great to see him doing so well
not just as an actor or knows art but as
a director as well and producer he's
just killing it it's great I know you're
doing Riviera which is a little more on
the drama side of things do you want to
do more drama if I can sure and I'm just
I'm open to kind of anything right now
yeah yeah don't take that too far I just
mean we didn't work do we know what the
rest development are you gonna come back
again at some point
this is kind of hard to say I know I
feel like you're just gonna kind of keep
on doing this for the next yeah I think
that might have reached my limit but
we'll see now the big mysteries with
bore Jack Horseman's yeah we do know the
the new seasons coming this year at some
point yeah but things have been very
vague yeah is there a reason for that
you're keeping things vague you don't
know we no one knows when this is going
to drop just because because I won't
tell me because there's that vague that
seemed like that but this year it's um
it is this year yeah we're working on it
or we're getting we're getting closer to
being done finishing up the season and
then we'll release it okay I can't say
what okay now not to end on a bad note
but I'm kind of surprised to see you
over the house I think it'd still be
morning to me beliefs getting kicked out
uh kicked out they lost they lots
they're no longer in the playoffs
they're done yeah they're done how do
you feel about this I don't feel great
about it I'm gonna be alieve totally
candid with you but we got a great squad
we got a great future what went wrong
I'm still it's still rough yeah it's
like a weakness oh I guess you know what
there's a lot of stuff that just could
have gone better um we you know
sometimes you get the bounces in the
brace and sometimes you don't we
couldn't scored enough where we should
have we hit a lot of post and and also
the the Bruins played they played us
well and they did a lot of like BS as
well you know and Brad Marchand oh yeah
thanks great well you know what laughter
is the best medicine laughter is and now
I'm back
happy birthday man thanks man appreciate
off